You are listening to radio lab radio from
W. N y. S. T. E. N. P. R
please enter your address for
Colorado calculating route.
Okay, now I'm getting closer to him. Woo.
We begin our journey this hour. How
old are you? I'm 42. Oh Man, I'm 63.
This isn't gonna work with this woman.
Her name is Sharon Roseman.
Okay. Enough of that.
We're going to talk about a little
predicament she got herself into. Um,
I was about five years old.
I lived in a small suburb
of Chicago called Maywood,
Illinois.
And I was outside playing on the
street or in a bunch of kids.
They were playing this game, blind man's
bluff. And she was the person who is,
it wears a blindfold and all the other
kids try and scatter around and they have
to freeze and then they can turn
to you and you can only hear them.
And the objective is basically to feel
around fall the voices until you tag
someone. Then they become
it. And that's what she does.
Everybody laughs because the person
that I tagged as kind of the loser,
you know, cause they found them first.
So I'm playing the game and they
took the blindfold off and suddenly
I didn't know where I was.
I didn't recognize anything,
this horrible panic set in because
nothing looked familiar to me.
Absolutely nothing. I just, uh,
I ran blindly just running, just to run,
cause I was so scared and I ran into the
backyard of this house in front of me
and I saw my mother sitting
in a lawn chair and I said,
why are you here? And she said, what?
What do you mean? Why am I here?
I said, why are you in this
backyard? Where are we? She said,
what are you talking about? We're at
home. I'm in the back yard. And he said,
but this is in our
house. And she said, yes,
this is what are you talking about?
And I couldn't explain it and I just
kept crying and just kept saying,
I don't know where I'm at.
And your mother must've been very
worried at that moment. Well,
unfortunately my mother said something
to me that actually changed my life
forever. She pointed her
finger in my face and she said,
don't ever tell anybody,
because they'll say you're a
witch and they'll burn you. What?
Shit? I don't know. I don't know.
And from that moment on, it was my secret.
She realizes now that what happened to
her in that moment when she was five and
playing the game was that her whole
world had rotated a quarter turn,
a quarter turn picture where
you're sitting right now. Yeah.
You would still be
sitting in that same room,
but the wall that you're looking at right
in front of you is now one wall over
to the right. Let me make it
easier. If I were on the toilet,
say sitting there looking straight ahead.
[inaudible] is now the bath
tub in a different place
than it was before the sink
in a different place by
about 90 degrees. Everything.
Everything in the entire universe, but
just horizontally. It doesn't tilt or no,
it doesn't tilt. East West becomes
north south, like in Colorado here,
the the mountains, the rocky mountains
are on the west end of town. Right.
When this happens to me, they
moved to the north end of town,
but everything else moves with it. So
the first time that happened did you,
you say you didn't know
where you were yet,
you recognize things but they just weren't
where they were supposed to be or I
didn't even recognize them that
very first time. I was so panicked.
I just didn't know what to
do. Did it ever happen again?
Over and over and over.
Okay. I mean I get lost
all the time as you, you,
but that's loose is different.
Yeah. Before we go any further,
let's just orient real quick. I'm
Chad at boom rod. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab. This hour we're
calling it the lost and found,
so I'm going to be experiencing the
feelings like Sharon pat of being totally
lost and then that relief that you feel
as Sharon will feel eventually of being
totally found.
Oh, not totally. Let's go back to
her story. Did it ever happen again?
Over and over and over.
She says this 90 degree rotation
problem would come on in all kinds of
situations. Sometimes even
when she had her eyes closed.
But what saved me was that
shortly after that first episode,
I went to a little birthday
party and we were playing, um,
pin the tail on the donkey and they
put a blindfold on me and spun me in
circles. You must've been like, oh
man, you want to do that? It was,
it was awful because after that
first turn, everything did shift.
But then on the second turn, when they
spun her around again, it fixed it.
Really? Yeah. Dizzy. That's so weird.
If I played a third time crazy again,
so it's binary. It's like on, off, on,
off. Sadly. Exactly. But I
couldn't tell anybody that,
but now she had a fix or a temporary
fix. So from that moment on,
anytime her world would shift,
I would go into the bathroom and I'd close
the door so nobody could see me and I
would spin in circles until it fixed it.
You spin and it reasserts
itself correctly. Yeah.
And I still do that to this day.
And with her secret spinning,
Sharon has managed to lead a
relatively life. She got married,
had three kids. When, when
my children were babies,
if one of them would cry out,
just cry out in their sleep.
Invariably she'd wake
up being into a while,
completely turned around and then
I would have to follow their cries,
the sound of their cries until
I could find the their bedroom.
There was no explanation for that.
I had to just say I was clumsy.
So you never told them? No.
And my husband didn't know and I'm
not married to him anymore. But um,
and you can leave that in there.
The point is she kept it a secret.
But one day when Sharon was 29,
she was on her way to her brother's house
and uh, she got turned around.
So I called him from a
pay phone and I said, I,
I can't find your house. She read him the
names of the street signs and he said,
Sharon, you're like two
blocks from my house.
And I just started crying
and I told him the story.
He was just shocked.
[inaudible]
so he dragged you to the hospital and
they saw some specialists and they kept me
in, um,
in the hospital for like a week doing
every kind of test you can imagine.
And it showed nothing.
They basically told me
it was psychological.
Like it's all in your head. Yes. Wow.
And that you were the only one in the
whole universe who had this problem? Yeah,
I thought, okay, I must be a witch.
[inaudible]
Huh? I mean that, that's, that's
just, that's a crazy story. Okay.
Just to pull out for a bit,
after we talked with Sharon,
we ended up speaking with them. Well,
if you've heard Radiolab before,
you probably know that voice. Um,
Jonah Lehrer literally asked him
like a question. Jonah Lehrer.
There you go. Jonah is a science
writer and an author. Uh,
my last book was how we decide
and it was a lot about the brain.
And so we played him tape from the Sharon
interview just to see what you think.
And he had an interesting
take. I mean, it just,
it just one of these great windows
into this talent we completely take for
granted. Um, and in you realize
this is such sophisticated software,
there are so many different algorithms
that are running that allow us to not get
lost in the way out of the bathroom.
One way to think about this story he
says is not why does Sharon get lost all
the time? But why don't the rest of us,
and a lot of this is brand new science
or we're talking the last three,
four or five years. But
in the time he says,
scientists have just begun to figure
out how brains make maps of our
surroundings from moment to moment.
They've identified at least four different
types of cells that make these maps
possible. Everything from place
cells to grid cells to border cells.
Like can we go through ways? So yeah,
no, we'll, we'll slow down. But, but,
but all these cells come together
to give us incredibly rich masters.
All began to make more sense to us when
Jonah said, okay, let me do it this way.
I just took a trip into this office,
but I'm sitting in a radio station and
let me do the same thing as I did it in
my brain. I got out of my car, I
walked to the front of the building.
So I open up the door
and somehow some way my brain
begins to make sense of this space.
First thing that happens, he says his
little cells in his head called red cells.
Come on mind grid cells are
pretty weird. I gotta be honest.
Before he's even taken a
step into the building,
these grid cells kind of like mappers
are surveyors. They lay on a grid.
It's great. This matrix over the
hallway right in front of him.
Unbeknownst to me, that grid is
composed of equal lateral triangles.
[inaudible] triangles. Yeah, it's,
it's pretty spooky. As I'm walking
down the hallway, I pass from
one triangle to the next.
My brain is keeping track of exactly which
triangle I'm in. I pass it by a wall,
so some border cells go off.
Avoid the concrete road,
just respond to borders,
edges, physical limits.
I look to my right and my
head direction cells change,
but then they change the act. Woo.
The erection l so there's a head direction
neuron firing all the time when I'm
facing dead ahead. When I turned my head
to the left, that neuron stops firing.
We have a new head
direction neuron firing.
Now I'm back to the deadhead.
I turned to the right new head
direction on firing that ahead.
These cells keep you oriented so you know
where you are in the grid and now it's
time to fill in the details. And
this is where things get really cool.
Proceed down the Cardo as
I take a couple more steps.
Now my place cells are probably
beginning to get active. It's the,
I'm here. So it's like for
every landmark in the space,
each body passes by the
brain will drop a little pin.
It's like an I'm here people. Yeah,
at the coffee table and then
I'm here at the potted plant in,
then I'm here at the
door or in the studio.
So now as I imagined myself walking from
this little closet like space back to
my car, as I pass by the coffee
table with the magazines,
that place I'll fire now and by the
front door, that place all fires.
Now I'm on the sidewalk. That place,
so fires now I'm by my car. That place,
so fires and when you put it all
together, the place sells the grid cells,
the boarders hell's what you get. He
says it's a symphony of electricity,
which somehow is translated for me
into an idea of a space
and this whole neural symphony,
it mostly takes place in that particular
part of the brain, hippocampus.
So if Jonah were to just
hazard a guess about Sharon,
she should get her hippocampus
checked at is you should do
meet me. You know? That's just a
guess. Now getting back to that story,
even though I was 29 I was
an adult. I had children.
The point at which we left off,
Sharon had gone to the hospital,
got in a bunch of tests and the doctors
had told her that I needed to go see a
psychiatrist. I felt like a freak.
Hello.
But then one day years after that,
I was watching some TV show,
Belgian scanning a crowd.
It was a newsy 2020 type thing
about face blindness, blindness,
people who can recognize faces.
And at the end of the show,
the reporter mentions this website, the
website, Sharon goes, she was curious.
And when she gets there,
this little window pops up that asks
her if she wants to take a survey.
I thought, well, I'll do it. And it was
mostly questions about face recognition.
But as I got deeper and
deeper into the questionnaire,
the questions start turning more to have
you ever experienced being in a place
that should look familiar to you but
suddenly does not. And I was like,
oh my gosh, that's me. And
asked for explanations.
So I was just typing away and typing away.
And eventually she meets the doctor
who had finally d, which her.
Uh, my name is Giuseppe urea.
I am a cognitive neuroscientist
at the University of Calgary.
And do you have a strong
sense of direction? And I'm
curious. I don't actually,
I am, I'm not a gifted direction.
Like you know Guy [inaudible]
but just said that had this idea that
maybe just like face blindness there could
be such a thing as location blindness.
So he asked Sharon to go
online and play this game,
sort of video games like virtual reality,
like where do you have to shoot people
and find people and Blah Blah Blah.
The screen would be showing you these
landmarks like a flower shop at Bar Bang
Bakery and then eventually I need it to
be able to to say where things are with
respect to one an order. Well No,
nothing now,
not even a guess for me and it actually
made me physically ill and then juice
up. He told her something
before you, I'd met this woman,
this lady who has complained about
orientation and she also failed this test.
So I brought her in to the lab and had
her play the game in this counter in the
MRI scanner in the brain scanner and we
were able to find activity all over the
brain except in one little place.
We were not able to detect any increased
activity within the hippocampus,
which just so happens to be though
home of Jonas little guys play
cell border, cell grid cells,
that particular part of the brain,
the hippocampus just never developed and
at that point that's when Giuseppe for
the first time told her this thing
has a name d t d for developmental
topographical disorientation
[inaudible]
and that's not trivial because when
something like this has a name,
suddenly it's not your fault. I felt
like I was reborn. I keep telling him,
you are my hero, you'll always be my
hero but have you ever met Sharon?
I mean face to face and we are, we
are supposed to meet now in this fall.
What if you like meet her and fall in
love with her and then she gets lost and
you rescue her and the science
is ruined. But you get married.
I am already [inaudible] never,
nevermind. But anyway. Do you set,
he's there.
He's got a couple of patients and he's
wondering how many other folks like this
are out there. So he puts
up a website. We said, okay,
we are looking for people who
have this specific symptoms.
One year later we were basically
dealing with 700 people.
We did say, oh see the same issue. Yeah.
So he sets up an Internet forum where
they can all talk to each other.
I'm the moderator and now
Sharon corresponds with
DTD sufferers from all over
the place. There are others out there
who experienced the 90 degree rotation.
Yeah. Oh, what about spinners though?
Do you have, you've ever met at spinner?
Yeah.
No, no, no.
Okay.
Actually I should get some lighter
cause if I look here, oh here.
Well there's one there
that, that one, that's fine.
But then another one she
wants later, I haven't drank.
She did another woman named
Sharon. My name is Sharon Mitchell.
The last name is m a. C. H.
E. L rhymes with Rachel. Okay.
When this Sharon heard about the first
Sharon, she says she bolted straight up.
There is a woman in Colorado
who has what I have and I,
it was such an emotional moment for me
that she decided to fly to Colorado to
meet Sharon Roseman and they
spent a day together. All right,
so let's just start with the easy stuff.
And they spoke with reporter Dave
Fender described yesterday. I mean,
what was it like to, uh, to get together
yesterday and yesterday was awesome.
I got out of the car and we just gave
each other a hug. And it was, it was,
it was a band that I've never experienced
with anybody else in my life ever.
We sat down right away in the
hotel lobby and started to laugh.
We couldn't stop laughing.
Everything we were telling our experiences
right away and comparing notes,
not even finishing our sentences. No,
we still don't know what's wrong with
Sharon and Sharon and the others.
We certainly don't know how
to fix it, but whereas before,
Sharon and Sharon were lost and alone,
now they're lost and together this
bond that we share, so in a wave,
it's like they're not really lost.
Like we sat there probably for 15
minutes describing how we were going to
navigate from this hotel to the shopping
mall that we could see right out the
window of the hotel and we had to come
up with some contingency plans. Yeah.
Yeah. So we had, we had
the gps if we needed it.
Sharon had a map in her hands if
we needed it. We had street names.
We were just hoping that at least one
of us was there instead instead of being
messed up. And so, um, we got there.
There it is. There it is. There it
is weird. Most stocks are jumping up.
It was really ridiculous if anybody and
they have no clue why we were so
excited that we found Nordstrom.
[inaudible]
big thanks to Molly Webster for
producing that piece with us.
More information on anything
you just heard or will hear.
Go to radio lab.org and you can
subscribe to our podcast there.
Hi,
this is Sharon Roseman radio lab is
funded in part by the Alfred p Sloan
Foundation. Okay.
I'm seeing public understanding of
science and technology in the modern war.
[inaudible] from Calgary.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org sorry,
I'm so late. I've been on the road.
I'm calling from my shelf on video that
is produced by WWE NYC and distributed
by NPR.
Hello, I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm Robert
Krulwich. This is radio lab today.
Our program is lost and found
approaching zone without
gps or it, well, you know,
I think we're getting real close on the
linear driving into our next adventure
is our producer Tim Howard.
Yes, yes. This is it.
So I sorted and I took a trip.
Your picture id to Fort
Monmouth, New Jersey.
For what? Fort Monmouth. Is
that a military base? Yup.
We were going to this
museum they have on the base
to meet you at the store to meet
this woman Mindy, Mindy rose,
what's on the museum curator at a US
army communications to show us around to
see what patients, Chad, do you wanna
hear some stories? Absolutely. Okay.
Here on display we have the war heroes.
So she pointed to this one glass
case, sort of like a memorial. Well,
he was born in 1918,
died here at Fort Monmouth in
1937 so he lived about 20 years,
served with the army expeditionary forces.
He was wounded and blinded in one eye,
carrying a very important message.
What's all this on his, on his
face there? Looks like putty.
Like what's all this stuff on his nose?
It's called crop and it's
a natural growth. Um,
I think it's a calcium growth
and some pigeons just get that.
Did she just say pigeons?
You got it. A lot of get it.
There's another one marker. I don't
know. Yeah, but he has one eye.
His eye was shot out in a second.
Tim, what's the story? Why Pigeons?
Pigeons. Yeah. Well
a pigeons are awesome. And B,
there's a big question here,
which is, well, let me,
let me just start you off.
Training wheels with a simple
little story on, this is GI Joe.
He's our hero pigeon, but there's one
pigeon named GI Joe GI Joe is pretty cool.
Well, he looks like a totally
ordinary pigeon. I wouldn't know that.
I'm standing a foot away from a
a war hero. I think he's cute.
He's got yellow legs. Remember I told
you about the legs? The feet. All right,
so what's the story? Okay, so
it's 1943 there was a town,
the British have just taken this little
Italian town call of the Chia full with
Chia from the Germans, the bad guys.
The problem is it took it really fast
and their American allies are about to
bomb the town in 20 minutes.
Oh, the radios are down.
They can't get anybody back to the base
in time to tell them to call it off.
How nearby is the space? 20 miles away.
And so they only really have one
option. Let me guess. No, wait,
just so you really get
this. Yeah, bring it home.
This bird is in a place
that he's never been before.
[inaudible] hallway there for
hours. He's been in a dark box.
He should be completely
confused. Should be.
And yet when they take him out and
throw them in the air [inaudible] like a
cosmic zip court. He's pulled
over mountains, lakes, forest.
None of which he's ever
seen before. Right back.
Yeah.
Did the army base where he lives just
in the nick of time, just as a bombers,
they're about to take off.
He's credited with saving
over thousands British live,
American hatched and GI Joe Kennedy,
the message through and
artillery bombardment in Italy
and the same units of the
56th London division.
How the hell did he do that? How
did he know exactly where to go?
Some of them returned with, um,
the message capsule hanging from their
leg and their breastbone shot open and
all that kind of stuff. But they
would always, um, fly back home.
How that's your question? Yep.
Hello? Hello there. So I called
this guy. This is Charlie Wolcott.
He's a heavy hitter in the vision world.
The former director of the
Cornell lab of ornithology.
My question is if GI Joe
had never been to that town,
how did he know
how to get back home? Well, the first
thing that GI Joe needs to know is where,
wait, wait, Tim, I'm sorry.
I feel bad for saying this because
it's your first piece for the show,
but I mean, don't we know the answer
to this? What's the answer, Jen? Oh,
birds have a compass in their
head. That's how they migrate. Jed.
You dummy.
You're just not getting
the degree of difficulty
about it. This way,
if I take you in a little boat and put
you out in the middle of a large body of
water, all you can see is
water and every direction.
Which way do you paddle to find New
York City? Are you asking me? Yeah.
Can I have a compass and this scenario?
Sure. But that's not going to help you.
Sure will. No, no.
What do you mean? No? Just think about it.
Which way are you going to paddle first?
Hmm. I
don't know enough to say yes
exactly.
It depends a little bit on whether
I've dumped you in the Atlantic Ocean,
the Pacific Ocean, the Indian
Ocean or whatever. Yeah,
you can't swim home if you don't
know which direction home is.
And you're saying this
is what a pigeon does.
You can throw it anywhere and
it knows. That's my whole point.
I W if you were a pigeon, I
wouldn't need to tell you anything.
Huh?
How did GI Joe figure out where
he is with relation to home?
That's the great question. That it, okay,
I'm with you now and I'm
sorry for interrupting you
earlier. That's all right.
So how do they do it? Well, and if
you have a one sentence answer for it,
then that's a short answer.
It is a very, very easy
answer. We don't know.
Wow.
But they have been doing a lot of crazy
experiments on pigeons over the years,
like 60 years now to try
and figure all this out.
Um, let us count the ways [inaudible].
We have tried flying pigeons
with frosted contact lenses.
They've put coils on their head
with the pigeons head like a hat.
They've glued little brass
weights to their backs.
They put radio transmitters
on them. Yes, indeed.
Dave followed pigeons in airplanes.
The point is that it is a complex issue
and they have definitely not arrived to
any consensus
for how pigeons do this. They have
theories, plenty of theories. Oh yeah.
For example,
you get talions Floriano poppy and his
colleagues believed that when you take
the pigeons out to the release point,
they sample the odors on the
way to the release point,
all the smells of the places
that they pass, right?
Essentially a series of
olfactory landmarks. You know,
you go past the chocolate factory and
the olive groves of the garlic plantation
or whatever sounds like a beautiful place.
And so when a pigeon is released, uh,
what it does is it sniffs
the breeze and says, Aha,
continue past garlic,
take a left at chocolate.
This is the odor that came to me on the
Northwind and therefore I need to fly
south in order to get home.
[inaudible]
but Charlie's actually put this idea, that
test or we anesthetized the
pigeons, put them in a box,
artificial air so they can't smell
anything and are rotating turntable and
transported them about
a hundred miles away.
And when they got over being kind of
car sick, they flew home just fine.
So something else is going on here. Yeah.
And here's where we get to my
personal favorite theory. All right,
forget about smell.
There are some researchers who think
that the key to pigeon navigation is,
are you ready for this?
Yeah. What is it? Metal,
which is to say if you go all the way
down into the center of the earth,
there's all this iron down there churning
and as it's churning it's throwing off
this magnetism.
Yes. Lines of magnetic force
through the earth out into space.
So imagine up there in the
atmosphere above the planet,
there are all these lines that are wiggly
and as GI Joe is flying through the
air is moving through these lines.
[inaudible]
do you think he sees the lines?
Well I can tell you that he might feel
them because there are these little
particles in his beat. Magnetite
magnetic iron particles.
They're twitching.
Some spots they twitch more in in
some spots less. And if you can
measure various aspects
of the magnetic field,
like its strength and its angle,
you can tell whereabouts you are.
Do you think that's
what's actually happening?
I think it may be partly what's
happening. I mean Charlie,
Charlie says there's probably
a lot of things going down.
Anytime you think you've figured it
out, the pigeon goes and messes you up.
For example, he told me about this
one place, a place in New York. Oh,
about 90 miles west of here
called Jersey Hill fire tower.
If we take Cornell pigeons to
Jersey Hill and let them go,
they go random and so
they are essentially lost.
It is a Bermuda Triangle
for Cornell pigeons.
Why would that be that? Sorry, I
hadn't, if we knew, I would tell you.
Is it a magnetic thing? No, no. There's
nothing magnetically disturbed about it.
Is it a sewage treatment capitol? No.
Hyper active radio
frequencies? No, it's a,
it's a hill surrounded by
pine trees. It's just a hill.
Does it make you wonder if there's a
whole other system going on in a pigeon
that we haven't even started
to think about? Yes, of course.
And then use you say, well,
what could it possibly be? Yeah.
And after a long day of,
of being out there with the pigeons and
releasing them and waiting for them to
make up their mind and fly home
and get the vanishing bearings.
You come back and you open the
loft and there they are, you know,
all sitting on their little
purchasers going, cool, cool.
And here's long to grab one by the scruff
of the neck and say, how do you do it?
But so far obviously they
haven't told us. Okay,
one more thing I didn't tell you
about how they were monogamous.
The pigeon mind might be unknowable,
but the pigeon heart
is an open book. Yeah.
Well Mindy said that with a lot
of other birds and chickens,
you get them all together.
They all go wild and party.
One thing leads to another. They all,
well maybe they go the
Jacuzzi, maybe they,
I don't know what they do in the
Jacuzzi. I'm not judging, but pigeons,
they would mate and they would stay
mated until death do they part.
So one thing you can do to make the pigeon
fly home faster is you take the male
out of his cage, you put another
male in there with his girl,
and of course he's
going to get pissed off.
This feathers are fluffing in who is the
straight male in my cage and all this
kind of stuff. Drive him away. He
flies back so fast to clean house.
So this is called the widow hood method
and yes, it is a powerful motivator.
Yeah, they miss the misses, so
wow. So who knows how he did it,
but what may have propelled GI Joe
through those darken war-torn skies was
jealous. Rage. A Ban could've Ben,
you go judge or you go get that
young buck [inaudible] you go ga Joe.
And if you have to save a thousand
lives in the meantime, okay, just do it.
[inaudible]
pretty good. Pretty good. Those pigeons.
But I think we can go one more round for
the human being and our natural ability
to navigate. I met a
woman named Lira Borucki.
She's in the psychology
department at Stanford University.
She studies languages and she's found
that some languages have a curiously,
I don't know how to put this a curiously
pigeon like power. No, seriously.
There are languages that don't rely
heavily on words like left and right and
some languages actually don't have
those words at all. Um, in the, uh,
culture I got to spend some time in,
they rely on north, south, east, west.
Oh, you mean like sort of taking
in left at the biscuit factory.
I'm going to hang it east
more so than that. Uh,
you would say things like there's an ant
on your southwest leg or move your cup
to the north northwest a little bit.
Where are we talking about, by the way?
I should back up. This story is
too good. You should start at the,
where are we in the world right now?
This is a community called pumper out
on Cape York. In Australia. Per Rao.
When was this? Uh, this
was a few years ago,
I guess 2006 there.
The way you say hello in
pumper out is you say,
which way are you going? Ah, so in
English you say, how are you? Fine.
In Palm you say, which way are you going?
And the answer must be something like
north, northeast in the middle distance.
How about you? What? Say, imagine as
you're walking around your studio,
each person that says hi to you,
you have to report your heading direction
to them so you literally can't get
past hello in this language without
knowing which way you're facing.
And you said North northwest
and the Middle Direction.
Is it really that that precise? It's
actually more precise than that.
There are 80 some
different choices. Oh yeah.
It was socially very awkward.
People thought I was quite dim because
I wasn't oriented and I didn't know
exactly which way it was, which all the
time you can ask a five year old there,
can you point northeast? And
they'll point without hesitation.
If you ask a Stanford professor or
Harvard professor to do the same thing,
they have no idea. It isn't. And that
you know what if you were indoors,
like what if you were in a, in a
shelter, could they still do it? Yep.
They keep track of directions
even when they're indoors,
how without windows you pay attention,
you just have to pay attention.
And I think what's really
striking about, um,
the discovery of languages like this and
folks like this as they have an ability
that we call dead reckoning and
it's an ability to, you know,
after any kind of circuitous path to
turn around and head straight back home.
That ability we thought
was beyond human capacity.
We had observed it an aunt and
we had observed it and birds,
but there was always
some other explanation.
Like birds have magnets in their beaks
and answer counting steps in, you know,
there's some kind of extra
thing that they were doing.
Now there's 7,000 languages in the world,
about a third of the world's
languages have this property. Hello,
not a third of the world's speakers, but
a third of the world's languages. Wow.
And these are not folks that have
magnets or special ant super powers.
They're using this, the same
cognitive system that we're using.
They're just using it differently.
They're paying attention to something
that we normally don't pay attention to.
But interestingly earlier
it says there was a moment,
a very particular moment when she
sort of slipped into attention.
I had this interesting
experience and I was there.
So after about a week
of being there, I was,
people were constantly pointing, uh,
to locations and I was constantly
trying to stay oriented.
And after about a week,
I was walking along,
I was kinda trudging through the sand.
It was hot and I was thinking
about whether I was wasting
my time there or not.
I wasn't sure if this
study was gonna work out.
And all of a sudden I noticed that in
my head there is this extra little,
it seemed almost like a
window, like an extra window.
Like in a video game there
was like a little console.
And in that console was a bird's eye view
of the landscape that I was walking on
and I was a little red dot. That
was traversing. Now that is kidding.
No kidding. And you just
become a pillow pole,
aloe or whatever they're called them.
And I thought, wow, that's really cool.
That makes it so much easier if you have
that little extra module in all of a
sudden is the correct word is that
you happened all of a sudden it, oh,
I just saw it. It was, it was just there.
And then I kind of shyly shared
this with someone. I said, you know,
this weird thing happened. I was
walking along and I got this,
I had this view in my mind and they'd
looked at me kind of strangely and said,
well of course. How else would you do
it? That's exactly the, of course, you,
you have a bird's eye view and you keep
track of your location from a birds eye
view. Of course. You do.
I have that all the time.
No you don't. I don't either.
Proceed to break. And by the way,
that voice right there that's been
joining us from time to time, uh,
we should explain that is Karen, Jake.
And I'm also known as the GPS girl.
She was nice enough to, uh,
agree to read some things that
we could use in our stories.
So that's what you've been hearing.
Okay. Well let's, shall we start with
the scripts that I have in front of me?
Okay. Please enter your address.
Well that's amazing.
It sounds like you've actually
gone into the machine somehow.
I don't work out how to
bottle that. Oh, I did.
Okay.
This is Jim Donahue
from Fort Worth. Texas.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of
science and technology in a modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I remember
the Krill, which this is radio lab.
Today on this program we are
calling it lost and found, right?
You have stories of getting lost
and of course getting found now.
I think we're gonna, we're gonna make a
little adjustment here. Recalculating.
Shift gears, approaching
emotional lift and thank God.
I don't know. Give it to me.
This next story is a very different kind
of lost and found sort of a love story.
If you can tell us your name. Oh, here's
the guy. My name is Alan [inaudible].
Do you want to say anything more
than that? I Dunno. Is this,
is this for like a credit intro?
Let people introduce themselves? Oh, I
don't know. I don't have a title. Okay.
All right. So that salad girl,
Emily will meet her a bit later
for reasons that will become clear.
The story begins on a
fall day in Brooklyn.
And so the day in question, um,
I guess was the morning of October 8th.
They're both living in this one room
loft in Brooklyn and we woke up and you
know, both 21 went about our
daily routine and prepared to go.
He was in art school,
she was taking some time off from art
school to work for a local artist.
So she would take the bike and I would
take the train. What was it morning like?
It was a beautiful day. It was, you
know, sun was low in the skies there,
you know, long shadows. I strapped
on her helmet and adjusted it,
took her bike out for her. We kissed
each other goodbye and said, I love you.
And I watched your ride down the street
[inaudible]
this early morning. And then you
know on, I went down into the subway,
six hours later he's working in the
studio doing some sculpture and he gets a
call from a cop and he
just said, Emily Goseo,
she had an accident. She said, Bellevue,
this is the address. And I said,
oh, I mean do you have any
more information? He just
told me that it was bad.
[inaudible]
I was like carrying a bunch of stuff and
I just dropped everything and started
running
[inaudible]
now Alan and Emily had only
been together nine months,
but when it started says Allen,
it was just so immediate.
The night they got together,
they both just kind of knew.
It was sort of like a weird prophetic
kind of thing where they think it was the
first day that the school has had
a snow day. It was snowed out.
It was kind of like this past blizzard,
you know, sort of like city shuts down,
magical kind of thing.
He'd gone out with some friends just
as the snow was coming down and we were
trapped at this party and that's
where he bumped into Emily pint sized.
Cause he's big like you're a desiccant
eyes and very kind of have trouble
describing your voice. It's almost as
if, I know you guys are audio people,
but it's like stereo. Almost. Truth is
they've known each other for a while,
but that night says Allen fireworks
all of a sudden. And it felt right.
So you had, you had a feeling this wasn't
just a thing, this was a thing. Right,
right. Or the thing, the thing, right.
The thing that you think the soul thing.
Yeah. All right.
Well Emily, uh, they've always
been boys frowned to Emily.
I mean that's Susan Gosu, Emily's mom.
She says at first when Emily told
her about Alan, she thought, okay,
so that's another boy.
Emily seemed to have that effect on boys
perhaps because she didn't really seem
to need them.
Here is someone who's been obsessed with
art and it's given up every body in her
life for art. At the age of six,
she was creating her own comic
books in junior high school.
She took drawing classes every night
and then in high school she left us
friends, boyfriends to go to a
high school of the arts in Florida.
No one stands in the way of her art. It's
all she sees, it's all she focuses on.
But then she visited Emily in May a few
months before the accident and she met
Allen. I met Alan and
he was delightful. Um,
but there was a different look that I'd
never seen in Emily's eyes before when
she looked at him and I didn't like it.
Tell us about the accident from your
perspective. From my, for when I, yeah,
I was at work. I, you're
in New Orleans mattering,
which is a suburb of New Orleans and I
get a telephone call and I looked and I
saw it was Allen Allen has never
called me before, answered the phone.
I said Hello Allen. And he
said, ah, you have to come.
Emily was hit by a truck,
uh, 18 wheelers, semi truck,
and I took a breath and I
said, Alan, is Emily dead?
And he said, no, but you need to get here
as soon as possible. Six hours later,
her and her husband, Emily's dad, we're
at Bellevue hospital here in Manhattan.
They brought us into the,
her Roman surgical ICU.
We all went in, she was just lying in
bed and they were tubes, tubes down,
her throat coming in and out
and her face was so swollen.
Emily covered in blood,
wait at probably at the
time of the accident,
about a hundred pounds and she then
weighed 128 she had swollen 28 pounds.
She had multiple fractures in her leg
and her pelvis in the left side of her
face
open her abdomen and they had taken her
intestines out and put them on top of
her body so that she could breathe
and she was just lying completely still.
You know that first 48
hours, nothing moved.
Not Nothing. We took up shifts, you know,
her mother would be there in the day
and her father in the evening and then I
would be there with her.
Her eyes weren't even flickering and as
she sat there watching Emily not move,
she says,
she kept thinking why I got these four
kids and everything bad seems to happen
to Emily starting at six months ear
infections than sinus infections than
asthma, than kindergarten. Emily was
losing her hearing for reasons
no one could quite figure out.
She had to get hearing aids on both
sides. But somehow her mom says,
all this just made Emily more
fierce if anyone can conquer this,
it's Emily.
I think on the second day they started
to take her off her medication,
expecting to see some sort
of reaction from her and
nothing,
nothing.
There was a nurse and the nurse said
that Emily was gone and asked me about
organ donations and I said yes. And so,
um, I worked up enough courage to go
into what they call the track room,
which is where the residents usually are.
And there was one woman residents sitting
at a computer and I went and I said,
when are you going to let Emily go?
And she's so we will have a family meeting
tomorrow morning and we'll talk then.
And so I said, okay. And I,
I left and I went back and,
and I'm sitting with Emily side
of her bed and I'm telling her,
Emily and I read the book,
the bridge of San Louis right
when she was a sophomore.
And I remember the ending of the
book, there's a land of the living,
there's a land of debt
and the bridge is love.
And that love is the only
thing that survives. And
it's kind of the way it goes.
And so I was sitting there with
Emily and I was telling this to,
I was saying this and talking in her ear
and saying this and talking to her and
telling her that I would love
her eternally through all time.
That I love with never end.
And Emily raised her left hand
did chick,
I got it. I can wait. What
was it was, it was k Hos
I was yelling for the nurse.
I saw it. I saw her move.
That was really one of the
really abrupt moments. Now
they knew Emily was not dead.
Emily was alive. But how alive
over the next few days says Allen,
she slowly started moving more,
not really in response to
anything. She'd arrive in bed,
scratch your leg where there was a wound,
hold her hand down and she'd
slap shit, slap our hands away.
But when they tell this to the doctors,
the doctors would say that's
not indicative of any kind
of mental functioning.
Could just be a reflex really.
So the medical team began trying to
determine just how damaged was she?
The ophthalmologists teams were coming
in and they were trying to get Emily's
eyes to eye peoples to respond
and they weren't responsive.
And so I knew what that meant. What did
that mean? It meant she could be blind.
So Emily couldn't see,
couldn't hear because remember she wore
hearing aids and why didn't you just put
those in? We tried. We tried
many times to put it in,
but she just wouldn't allow it. But
what you do exactly when you did it,
flail her head shake around
kick and she would hit,
had a lot of bruises on my body where
she'd kicked me and pitched. So we,
we stopped. We every once in a
while we would go back to it,
but there was the question, you know,
um, maybe she couldn't hear anymore.
So what do you, what do you
do to a person who's gay?
You don't know what's going on inside
her and you can't get to her. Um,
you send it to a nursing
home and you know,
that's where she would have remained.
And after several weeks in the ICU,
Emily, she was stable and that
meant they had to make a decision.
Once you become stable,
then you have to move off surgical ICU
and out of the hospital to either a
rehabilitation or to a nursing home.
So that became the new question.
Where would she go? Could
she be repaired, so to speak?
In which case you'd go to
Rehab or is it for her?
In which case she'd go to a nursing home.
Now making that call
medically is sometimes tricky.
That's Dr McCalla Eisenberg.
She's a physician at NYU and
it's her job to make that call.
And she says one of the key criteria for
getting someone into rehab to do Rehab
on somebody, you need to
have them reacting to you.
A person needs to be able to participate
in a meaningful way for three hours of
therapy a day.
They have to be able to follow commands
because that's how you rehabilitate
someone. If the person can't
hear, if the person can't see,
then there's no way to
communicate with her.
And so they made the assessment that
she could not go to rehab and that Emily
should go to a nursing home.
Mm MM.
So I sent my husband back to New
Orleans to look for a nursing home.
Did they can bring her back to,
they just kept it all secret from me that
they were going to take her away from
me. I mean, how do you
tell someone who loves your daughter
that much? That we're taking her away.
But there was not just one life that
we had in our hands. It was two lives.
We felt that that would
be the best thing for him.
And Alan could hate us.
[inaudible]
maybe as a way for him to bridge
and let go for that grief.
[inaudible]
but then as the doctors are prepping
Emily to move her to a nursing home,
they had to remove her tracheotomy,
which was helping her breathe.
And she all of a sudden started
talking. Really? She, she spoke? Yes.
What was she saying? He
would curse. Don't touch me.
You blank to blank. You
know, she would say, stop.
This was in response to someone
touching her, touching her.
And if she wasn't cursing, says Ellen,
she would call everybody Miss Dash.
Would certain people that were touching
her where mustache would, oh, let's,
um, from sentence sensibility
coding gene aust yellow. Yeah.
We had watched the movie like a
couple months previous to this,
so somehow she was locked in the movie
and it was just the assumption of the
doctors that she was
just sort of mentally,
but if she's calling people miss dash,
doesn't that at least mean something? No,
it wasn't enough to say that Emily
could follow a command, like set up,
raise your right hand. So the plan
was still the nursing home, right?
I mean though, every possibility had
not been exhausted. I can see him.
He was sitting across the room
and his jaws were just clenched.
It just was not going to
give up. And he was saying,
you have to give her a chance. She,
you have to give her the chance.
You have a plan. No, I had no
plan whatsoever. It was lost.
This experience was just completely
traumatic to me emotionally.
But at the same time I was going to
help her in whatever way I could. Uh,
the only trajectory I had
was to help her in one night,
just a few days before Emily was going
to be discharged to a nursing home away
from him. I was there alone with
her and it's 3:00 AM or something,
and she was calm. Like she wasn't
trying to fight me away or anything.
I had helped her fix a thing that
was wrong with her, uh, mouth wiring.
It was like a wire that was
poking her and I fixed it for it.
And he says at that moment, something
occurred to him. I really just was like,
in the recesses of my mind,
he thought of the story of
Helen Keller and Annie Sullivan.
He'd read about it a few days
earlier online and he thought,
what if I tried what Annie Sullivan
did with Helen Keller on Emily?
I took her left hand with my left hand
and I leaned over and using her wrist as
the baseline for the words. And
his finger is the pen I just wrote.
I waited a second. Oh, wait a second.
Oh, waited a second. The e
waited a second. You then according
to Allen, she said to him,
she said, Oh, you love me. Thank you.
She literally replied the
reply immediately because
she knew who, you know,
she has no idea who I am.
Uh,
now we had a way to get to her so he
could figure out how much of her was
actually there and maybe even
prove it to the doctors. You know,
I had to have something that was
conclusive to present to them.
The following evening I took out my cell
phone and it has a record function on
it and I started recording
question after question to
determine her Tonya disability.
What is your name?
What? W. H. A. T. Hi.
Yes, I am.
Hey,
you finger spelled every letter. Yeah.
[inaudible] Hi
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] she's
writing her name on the poem of mine.
Alan called me at four o'clock in the
morning, said, you have to come now.
I have proof.
No one's going to ask her what year it is.
[inaudible] hi, I'm going to ride year.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
question mark. Very good.
And Emily. Very good. Very, very good.
You know where you a question mark?
Okay. Right now I'm going to ride hospital
that they're about four 45 in the morning.
Alan is over there by the bed continuing
to finger spell and talk to her and
she, she calls him Allen.
She knows that this person who is finger
spelling on her hand is named Allen,
but Allen can't get her to understand
who he really is. That it's her alley.
I'm just going to read
my name again. Alan.
She just couldn't make that mental
jump to connect her past life with her
present.
I
[inaudible] am I Asian or no?
Next thing I hear her say
is pull me out of the wall.
She kept saying, pull me out. Please
pull me out of here. It's dark in here.
Pull me out, help me know you can
do it. Pull me out of the wall.
I kept saying I can't, I would
write on her hand that can't,
Allen starts to sob and I'm crying too.
What are you thinking at this point?
It wasn't enough. It wasn't enough.
It wasn't enough. And I said, Allen
ask her about her hearing
aids and so he finger spells,
hearing aid aid and she said okay.
She agreed with the hearing
aid and for the first time,
so we put it in and
switched it on. He said,
Emily, Emily, can you
hear me? It's me, Ellen.
Everything came back to me. I
there. I did not read everything.
The door opened and Emily stepped out.
She was back. Yeah. It's just a hearing.
His voice. I knew it was Han and I.
He sent anomalies there
and I heard her say what?
I had been waiting for her to say all
those weeks I screamed, mom, you know he,
she said, Mama, no, I couldn't
leave her there the whole time.
We asked Emily before she
came back, where was she?
I didn't know where I was.
If I could see at all,
and I knew that I was sleeping
and I was already dreaming.
She says people would come to
her in her dreams and say, don't,
don't touch that. Stop
scratching your wounds.
And I dreamed they blend in with reality.
She says she knew somehow that
there are people around her,
but she couldn't get to them and that
she also knew she was in a dream.
Why am I still sleeping? But you
couldn't send my awake up from,
I felt helpless. I felt really helpless.
Where you waiting for someone
like that? I mean, where are you?
Because I was waiting for
some communication, you know,
[inaudible] and I always
really [inaudible]
[inaudible]
Alan, he's very call to me.
Emily's now at the Rusk Institute,
which is one of New York
city's leading rehab centers,
and on the day we visited her, she just
had a breakthrough. I said, first day,
okay, stand on both legs
and walk. Actually walk.
I walked a hundred feet today
after Rehab, she'll be moving into an
apartment in lower Manhattan with Allen.
She's blind. And the chances
of receiving again are slim.
But Allen plans to spend his time helping
her cope and helping her find a new
way to make art. Really. Can
you, can you introduce yourself?
Do you want me say, my name is Allie?
Yeah. Just with, just so we have it all
on tape. If I would have the title on,
I couldn't think of one, but
I thought of one title. Yeah.
And I'll do mine. My name is
Alan llangoed. Um, the boyfriend,
my name is [inaudible] and the girlfriend.
You're the star of the
show then that. Okay.
If you want to know more about Alan and
Emily, go to our website, radiolab.org.
You can do all kinds of things there.
Like subscribe to our podcast, I guess.
Uh, we should go. Yeah.
Thanks for listening. You
have reached your destination.
Oh, and thanks to Karen [inaudible].